i had so much fun with this movie i mean
especially for rtu as a kid like this
seems like a dream movie where you can
just
do things to people and not get in
trouble for it
yes i do enjoy inflicting pain on other
people
two in particular
too particularly
is that english we're we're teaching him
english at the moment
yes both of them are good versions of
the sentences okay
when you read the script was there any
of these any of the things that you do
to these two individuals was were there
anything you were most excited about
getting to do to them
most excited for was probably
it had to be
shooting rob
with um a pool ball in terms of like the
the most high hype i had for
some of the scenes it had to be shooting
rob with a
pool ball cannon yeah because i i felt
like i was like well this professional
hit man
six six rounds
and then rob had like this disgusting
makeup on with the boil and he would
just walk around that all the time and
it was really yeah
it looked a conversation
um so that was an odd an odd day at work
yeah
ashley what was it like for you to work
with archie and find that bond as you
know playing his mother in this like how
did you guys find that really quickly
yeah i think it was quite easy actually
we got along straight away very well and
he's um drinking water now which is a
classic sign when an actor doesn't want
to answer a question
and this is your question i think it was
a giant honor for him to get to work
with me so
you know he was really excited and sorry
you were drinking your water so i filled
in what you would have said um but yeah
we got along straight away and i think
that's really important
in any acting dynamic where you're
playing something where you have to
quickly establish that there's a
relationship already whether it's um a
romance or a marriage or a mother and
son or whatever it is that you want the
audience to believe that this isn't two
actors meeting for the first time so
that made it a lot easier
yeah i mean obviously you want the
audience to get a little teary-eyed when
they finally get you know are able to
get back together and reunite yeah
it definitely made me a little bit
teary-eyed when you know
understanding what this mother had to go
through to get back to the sun
christina radish i don't ever want to
make you cry
well archie
i mean your
first movie was jojo rabbit and
it's been a little bit of time since
then so do you feel different as an
actor now what what is it what was it
like to do this experience for you do
you feel the responsibility of leading a
movie
so
uh i have matured a lot since jojo
rabbit and it is
the roles are like maturing with me so
like
now that i'm turning into a teenager
pretty soon like february the clock
comes i guess
we're both pisces yeah
but possibly
how did it feel when you were first
acting in jojo rabbit was everything
like it was
i was like blown away nervous excited
all at the same time
and um
like
i'm i'm gradually getting more used to
it now yeah i feel with every single
role that i do
and i'm just so happy that i get to try
out new things now that i've done two
comedy films i want to start trying out
drama maybe action maybe horror maybe
maybe strategy maybe burping maybe
[Laughter]
that was one of his accents that was him
pretending to be in star wars
yeah i was gonna say i feel like now
that you're you know part of the disney
family you can they need to make you a
superhero at some point
yeah
i mean i think i have the i have the
natural superhero curl whenever my hair
isn't done up that's so true you have
clark kent naturally you could be a
young clark kent superman take off your
glasses
absolutely no idea who he is
absolutely no idea it's unbelievable
put them back on
incredibly transformative incredibly
transformative laser eyes
yeah as in he's going to get laser eye
surgery so he doesn't need
glasses
well actually this this character is
mischievous and he's resourceful do you
feel like you are both of those things
yourself
do you feel like you're one more than
the other do you feel like you're
neither of those things
um
resourceful
guess so yeah
um mischievous not so much serious i
don't know you you're rebranding
yourself
i know when i can do things that get me
into trouble and don't do them yes
that's fair he's a he's a very good kid
but you're also collecting lots of like
science data yes for explosions and
stuff like that at the moment like the
mentos and coke thing was a big thing
manganese hyptoxide manganese hot flavor
it's you know it's harder to do science
than you think apparently
ashley what was it like to do some of
these big loud chaotic family scenes i
mean there are a lot of people in some
of these
moments
yeah
though those feel like um
there's the obvious moments that are uh
nods to the first movies thematically
but actually from um
from a
shot point of view something like
following a child's eyes around the
family and the christmas noise and the
travel that's a real um i think
cinematography
that's quite a big homage to the first
movies and sort of be part of that like
they're the ones we all we all remember
is being brought around a house and
discovering all the characters through a
child's eyes with the camera following
them so that was always it was always
just a bit nerve-wrecking that you know
when the camera came around and you're
sort of ready for your bit that you
don't go
and look down the camera by accident and
then the whole thing's ruined but those
things were really nice to do
as a as a collaboration with all the
different moving parts it's quite fun
because it keeps it a little bit fresh
and live on set
yeah those kind of scenes seem a little
bit scary too because if one thing is
off it sort of ruins the whole thing
yeah if someone just sort of turns
around and goes huh you know the whole
thing needs to be redone so
or if you forget your line or something
like that you want to be that guy
was there a lot of like cracking up on
this set were there were there a lot of
laughs during takes when when we were
doing that particular scene actually
pete holmes's character is
asking the
about what you call the home computer
like voice
home bot and he did loads of different
versions of it and that was really funny
so every time he just like do and knew
it so we'd all slightly be waiting half
in character half of ourselves to see
what pete holmes would say this time
around
well thank you guys for talking to you
you are delightful in the movie or
delightful just together there so thank
you so much oh thank you i'm going to
name a character in one of my next
writing projects after your surname so
if you see radish pop up that is
absolutely will know it was all thanks
to this moment thank you
thank you so much
you